hey how's everybody doing today hope
everybody's having a good day first off
I want to mention the giveaway real
quick if you participated in the
giveaway then stick around until the
very end of this video so you can find
out if you won and you can find out the
details about my next one so I want to
thank all you guys who participated in
that and everybody that subscribed to
this channel and played along with those
thanks guys
now I want to get started with today's
video and I want to mostly talk about
your own Greyjoy but I also want to
discuss his alliance with Cersei
Lannister and how I think those two
together are going to be the biggest
threat during season 7 and if you've
been a subscriber here for a very long
time then you will have seen a video I
made about this probably about two
months ago and I briefly discuss some of
this stuff but now that I have new
spoiler photos and I also have some more
information that I'm using from the
books I think you're going to like this
version a little bit better and I know
some of you guys are probably going to
think that this is [ __ ]
and you're going to think that the
biggest threat is the night's king which
is true but they're still going to be
stuck behind that wall for the entire
seventh season so for right now John and
Danny they're going to have to take care
of you're on and Cersei first and it's
not going to be easy by any means I
think you're on Greyjoy is one of the
most overlooked players in the game
right now pretty much because the
television show hasn't done a very good
job with his character they kind of made
him look and sound like a douchebag in
my opinion and I'm not even sure if the
average Game of Thrones fan is aware of
his actual appearance and what he is
actually capable of Euron looks
completely different in the books
his hair is actually black and he wears
a black patch over his eye and it's even
thought that he may have used the magic
of the dark arts to keep himself looking
young and another interesting feature he
has is his blue stained lips you're on
consume shade of the evening on a
regular basis I think it would actually
be safe to say that he might be addicted
to the [ __ ] shade of the evening is a
hallucinogenic sort of like acid or
mushrooms which I don't think is
something you want to be taking when you
are already a deranged man I think Iran
is a complete psychopath and drinking
this [ __ ] makes me wonder if Eve
knows the difference between
hallucinations and reality his
perception is definitely warped and
everyone was already wondering who the
next villain could be during season
seven and I think you're on definitely
fits that bill he takes things to a
whole nother level in my opinion
compared to Joffrey and Ramsay Euron
hasn't just killed one family member but
he actually murdered three of his
brothers and he has now on a mission to
murder his niece and nephew Theon and
Yara and euron greyjoy is a very
dangerous man he may be known for
playing mind games and psychological
warfare but he is completely
unpredictable and absolutely ruthless I
think it's also safe to say that you're
on is as skilled a warrior at sea as the
Dothraki are an open field in one of the
most famous things he is known for is
his ship silence he says that men start
to pray when they see his sails and the
men that crew the ship or mutes Euron
had all their tongues ripped out because
he needed silence I don't think he
wanted word to get out that he was
actually starting to go insane in
drinking shade of the evening on top of
already disturbed mine is a deadly
combination but he has also done more
disgusting things as well when he would
drink too much he would go into one of
his brother's rooms and molest him so
much so that his brother Aaron still has
nightmares about it and he also raped
and impregnated his brother Victorians
wife she was kind of more like a
concubine but it was still his wife
nevertheless and just to screw with his
brothers head he would actually tell
Victarion that he seduced her that he
didn't rape her just to be a prick but
Victarion ended up beating her to death
and that is what actually led to Iran
being exiled from the Iron Islands
Victarion wanted to kill him but Ken
slang is typically a big no-no but
that's something obviously Iran doesn't
abide by and ever since he was exiled he
has been traveling the world raping and
weaving ever since he also has a bunch
of bastard tailed Rijn as well but he
pretty much compares them to what is in
his chamber pod
Euron Greyjoy gives zero [ __ ] for real
and during one of his raids around Qarth
Joran attacked and captured some
warlocks who most men dread but again
Euron shows no fear he tortured the
warlocks until they showed him their
black magic he had four of the prisoners
at first but one of them actually had
the balls to threaten Euron so he killed
him and fed his flesh to the other three
warlocks so if you haven't read the
books hopefully by now you can start to
see what type of person he actually is
he shows no mercy
not even to his family and when him and
Cersei formed their alliance combining
these two personalities could lead to
absolute devastation and if you're on
has what I think he has Daenerys is
going to be in for a big surprise when
you're on showed back up in the Iron
Islands he murdered his brother Balin
who was king of the Iron Islands at the
time and by doing this it put him in
position to command the entire fleet and
during the Kingsmoot Joran reveals that
he has dragon binder which is thought to
be made from an enormous dragon it has a
black gleam and is banded with red gold
and Valyrian steel and when touched the
Horn feels warm and smooth its surface
is shiny and reflective though the
reflection depicted is twisted the bands
of the horn are covered by strange
writing Valyrian glyphs which reads I am
dragon binder no mortal man should sound
me and live blood for fire fire for
blood the horns noise sounds like the
screaming of a thousand souls and it
seems to listeners as if their very
bones are aflame in searing their flesh
from within urine has Cragg horn blow
the horn he collapses and immediately
has blisters on his lips in the tattoo
of a bird that is when his chest starts
to bleed and later when a maester
examines his body he discovers that as
long as a shard as black as soot or coal
and we all know you're on when's the
Kingsmoot next by promising the iron men
that they will conquer Westeros with
dragons
Euron then has his crew caps
Aaron damn fair he forces damn fair to
drink shade of the evening and he has
visions of urine on a throne of skulls
and later urine as a Kraken Lake figure
with tentacles on the Iron Throne with a
woman by his side and I think that woman
is going to be Cersei Lannister
I don't think Iran is going to be
sitting on the Iron Throne but this is
going to be the beginning of a
beautifully twisted relationship between
these two
now that yar and Theon took off with his
best ships to give to Daenerys for help
Euron is having his own ships built and
when he catches up to them on sea they
will not be able to stop him out there
at sea is where Euron will be his
strongest he knows the water like the
dragons know the sky and when he takes
out your as fleet and captures her in
the sand snakes it will be just what he
needs to walk right up to Cersei on the
Iron Throne
Euron will offer her his ships just like
he would have worked in Eris Euron
actually orchestrated an attack at
Lannisport which wiped out Tywin
Lannister's fleet but when Euron shows
up with a thousand ships three enemy
prisoners and a dragon horn all will be
forgiven
Cersei will have just what she needs to
put a tough fight up the Martel's are
going to be completely wiped out the
show is done with Dorne the Tyrells are
going to be completely wiped out by
midseason when Jaime attacks Highgarden
and the tarly's will no longer be a
threat because we know from spoilers
that they are double-crossing the
Tyrells and joining forces with the
Lannisters the phrase are no longer
going to be a threat either and after
Euron takes out yours fleet he will now
be in sole command of what Ironborn is
left I think when you're on and Cersei
team up it's going to make for some very
exciting television Cersei is gonna send
Jaime to Highgarden which we'll leave
you're on there without Jaime being in
the way for some time and once Jaime is
gone Euron's going to walk right up to
Cersei and grab her by the well you know
what I mean
and if Cersei has the mountain in the
Lannister forces and she has a fleet
with a thousand ships being led by euron
greyjoy plus a dragon horn and wildfire
then Daenerys is really going to need to
come up with a good strategy when
she plans her attack on King's Landing
Cersei and Euron will never bend the
knee and I think the dragon pit scene is
just going to be a front if anything at
all and speaking of the dragon pit I
don't think they rented out that pit
just for a parlay scene I think you
could do a parlay scene anywhere I think
they are introducing the dragon pit
because that's where Cersei and Euron
are going to eventually keep the dragon
that they bind at least for a short
period of time but anyways tell me what
you guys think all this I feel very
confident that we will see all of this
and I personally want them to be able to
show your ons character the right way I
wish they had more time to go in depth
with this character but I feel like they
still have a chance to accurately show
just how brutal he is at least I hope so
but now it's time to announce the winner
of the game of Thrones novel and t-shirt
giveaway but before I announce the
winner I want to let everyone know that
at the end of this month I will be doing
a giveaway that is better than all of
the other ones combined and I'm not
saying what it is yet but I will reveal
that in upcoming video this week but if
you want to be a part of it just
subscribe to this channel before the end
of this month for your chance to win my
greatest giveaway to date also like the
video - please appreciate it guys
but now the winner of the game of
Thrones t-shirt and book is drumroll
please Douglas Ward congratulations Doug
you were randomly selected this time so
just send me a message or DM me on
Twitter that way I can get your address
to send this stuff out to you as soon as
possible and also I need to know your
shirt size too and thank you to everyone
that has participated and shown support
better luck next time guys and I will
see you in the next one bye